hey everyone today I'm going to show you
how to create 3D depth in After Effects
like you see in this example here it's
actually relatively easy and all we need
is a few lights a camera and some photos
so let's dive
[Music]
in hey everyone my name is Cameron with
motion science and if you're new to the
channel welcome today we're talking
about how to create depth in After
Effects using 3D lights cameras and
photography now if you're new to the
channel I do want to invite you to
download my free pdf guide the complete
guide to organic design in motion design
these are tips and tricks that I use in
my own workflow to create the work that
you see here on this YouTube page uh
these are super simple techniques that
will elevate your design to a whole new
level if you're tired of digital design
and you want that more cinematic feel
definitely download the guide It's
motion science. tvguide it's it's
absolutely free go download it after
this video okay so let's dive in and
let's explore how to create 3D depth and
after effects okay so here we are blank
canvas I've got a composition set up
it's 8 seconds long it's 1920 x 1080 24
frames per second click okay and the
first I'm going to do is I'm going to
bring in this texture I have here this
is a texture I like to use for a variety
of projects and it's just a simple
scratch texture like we see here and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
actually scale this way up something
around here and I'm going to hit this
little tick box right here to make this
layer 3D and I'm going to push this back
in 3D space and it might be easier to
see this by going to two views and
scooting this window over and on this
perspective we're going to change it to
top and if I zoom out you can see here
is our layer and I'm going to push it
way back in 3D space now what we're
going to do is we're going to bring in
some mockups that I have that I created
in Photoshop what I did is I went into a
stock site and I downloaded these
templates that have a rough torn Edge to
them and I plugged into these templates
photography that I generated in mid
Journey so these are all AI photos and I
wanted to do kind of a cold war spy type
theme so there's image one image two
image three image 4 five and six so back
and after effects here are the the
mockups I'm just going to command C to
copy and go into my composition here and
command V to paste and then it's super
important that I took the 3D box here to
make these 3D layers and then the next
part here is a little bit timec
consuming it's just me moving these
layers around in 3D space I'm moving
them
back like so it's just going to take me
a little bit of time to get these in
place so let me go ahead and speed
through this
process
now I've got these layers in 3D space
but it's kind of hard to tell what's
going on so what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to add a camera by going to
layer new camera and we're going to use
a one node camera I'm a big believer in
one- node cameras they're simpler to use
than a two- node camera I have many
videos here on YouTube about this uh and
we're going to turn off depth of field
for the moment and use a 35mm preset
like we see here and click okay okay so
let's add a little bit of rotation to
this camera so we're going to hit R for
rotation and let's put in a value of
seven and it's just going to rotate the
scene now I saw the background rotate
but I didn't see the photographs rotate
and that's because these Photoshop files
are set up with pre-ms within them like
I showed uh earlier like we can see here
these are all pre-ms so what we need to
do is we need to double click and we're
going to move into each of these pre-ms
and make them 3D so let me show you on
this middle piece here if I if I double
click it and I go in and I take both
these layers and make them 3D go back in
here you can see that that photo rotated
cuz it's reacting to the camera now so
we need to do that for each one of these
we're double click make
3D double click
3D and double click
3D and you can see now all the photos
are rotated and they're reacting to the
camera so let's go ahead and just close
these precom so we have less here on our
timeline to look at and next what we're
going to do here is I'm going to go back
to beginning my timeline and I'm going
to hit P for position on the camera I'm
going to set a key frame and I'm going
to hit C to bring up my camera tools and
this tool here is a pan tool so I can
move this and I can go back here and I
can set kind of a start point which I
like something like this and then I'll
go to at the end of the timeline and
I'll use my same camera tool and just
drag somewhere up in here looks great so
now we have a nice simple movement
across and you can see we're already
getting some depth because we took the
time to layer these pre-ms in 3D space
and after effects now immediately this
foreground one that we see here uh is
distracting it's just too big it's in
our face so let's actually scoot this
one I like this left edge better so
let's go to the end of our timeline here
and let's bring it actually we don't
want to move that one so let's go ahead
and lock that
one and let's
find this element here and let's just
bring it
across and I want to see this left Edge
so that looks nice something like that
and maybe scale it down a bit doesn't
need to be so big in in our face that
looks nice now let's go ahead and lock
that one as well and let's just position
this one maybe a little down take this
one
move it I kind of like them to overlap a
little bit looks
nice go here to the beginning and we'll
do the same thing we'll move this one
down and kind of move this
one you know
something I said it doesn't have to be
perfect let's lock that background and
let's take this one and maybe bring it
down a bit and then we'll just kind of
move through our timeline again it's
looking pretty cool it's got some
interesting depth to it now I should
mention that I was in inspired to create
this piece because I saw something on
Pinterest and if you're not following
motion science on Pinterest definitely
do there's a lot of great inspiration
boards there for you to look at but this
piece had this red string that went
across it was almost like it was on a on
a push board and the red string was
connecting each of these photographs
like it was an investigation and that's
what I wanted to kind of emulate here
and it also give it some more additional
depth by having a string kind of going
across the scene so I have a string that
I again pulled in from a stock site
pretty boring at this point but we can
tint this to make it red and you know
more Moody and a little bit more
interesting so let's go ahead and do
that we're going to go up to effect
color correction and we're going to use
tint and we're going to map white to
this red color that I found right here
which is really nice so now I'm going to
make this layer 3D and disappears on us
and we need to bring this forward in
zspace we'll go back to our two views
here and you can see that and we'll
bring It Forward oh
about let's make it negative 500 I like
to use even numbers when positioning
things in 3D space and after effects it
just keeps things simpler for me uh and
again it's it's missing here so where is
it at let's just bring it down there it
is right there and it's really big so
let's go ahead and scale this
down maybe something like
30 and then what I'm going to do here is
just bring this in and position it
rotate it hit R for
rotation and kind of just play
around with positioning here and again
this can be kind of
tedious but we just want to look like
it's you know connecting maybe different
photographs I'm going to command D to
duplicate and let's bring this one
maybe across like
[Music]
this and let's duplicate again R for
rotation maybe bring this
one maybe up in here we also don't want
to overwhelm the scene with too much of
this
string
now this one here is bothering me
because it looks like
it's kind of attached to that first one
which I don't want it to I want to have
a little bit more spacing between them R
rotation you know maybe something like
that and I'm looking to make sure that I
don't catch the end of these at all
that's looking pretty cool so let's also
give it a little bit more visual
Movement by animating the string so I'm
going to find this string which is this
one right here and I'm going to solo it
I'm going to go to effect transition and
I'm going to find the linear
wipe and Let's do let's just so you can
see I'm just pulling the transition
completion to adjust this now I want to
make it go the other way so I'm going to
go negative 90°
here and we're just going to start maybe
something like right in here we don't
have to always start at zero and let's
turn up the
feather just a little bit and we'll set
a key frame here transition completeness
and I'm looking to see when does this
string leave the frame looks like it's
around here so at this point I want
the actually want to go the other way
here
so if we watch this back you can see
like the string is growing as we're
following which is interesting let's go
find the next string here maybe this
one's already there and then we'll find
the first one
here and we'll select this top one with
a linear wipe
again and maybe have it start just off
screen there
give it a little bit of
feather and have
it come
down so it just gives us a little bit of
added like secondary animation which is
nice and it may or may not work we'll
find out here in just a minute go ahead
and save that now comes the key is
adding some lights to really give this
some added Dimension so what we're going
to do is we're going to go to layer new
light and we're going to select a
spotlight 100% intensity is great cone
angle 61 great cast Shadows we want to
make sure that this is ticked click okay
and then we're going to hit P for
position and we're going to back this
light up so that it affects a little bit
more of the
area and I found like I liked this
position here then we're going to
duplicate this light and we're going to
hit P for position and we're going to
move it over here and then we're going
to actually open up the point of
Interest here and bring over the point
of Interest
here now we've got some lights but we
don't have any Shadows right so we need
to tell these layers to cast Shadows
again we can jump into these pre-ms and
for each one of these make them cast
Shadows or we can come in here and we
can turn off this little button right
there and then select all and then open
up just one of them and under material
options we're going to tick cast Shadows
on and you're going to see everything's
casting Shadows now and just to be sure
you could go into the next layer here
layer
eight open it up material options cast
Shadows it should be on so so looks like
we're good to go
there and you can see now this piece has
some really
interesting
depth in it right now there's a little
bit like we're not seeing so much on the
string on the left side here so what we
can do is just start positioning our
spotlights so we can play around with
our point of
Interest our actual
position same with the spotlight
one
and the thing I'm noticing also is our
strings are not casting Shadows so we're
going to select all them we're going to
open up layer material options and we're
going to cast Shadows on and you can see
instantly there's the Shadows that are
appearing from the strings now there's
some stark contrast between the light
areas and the dark areas so to fix that
to bring a little bit more Ambience to
the rest of the scene we're going to add
an ambient light so layer new light and
we're going to select ambient light and
we're going to turn this way down to
something like 10% and click okay and
ambient light does not cash Shadows but
it brings light to the overall scene so
that we can see more of what's
happening so I really like this I do
want to bring my Spotlight
one point of Interest back over here a
bit position it
play around the position a little
bit bring this photograph
in just a
bit and this is where we just start kind
of playing around
with the composition to kind of balance
it
out
and one effect I'm really into right now
is film emulation by dehancer so I'm
going to add that over the top layer new
adjustment
layer film emulation dehancer
Pro and I really like the preset for
Fuji color 100 I'm also going to turn
on Bloom there we go it's looking pretty
awesome at this point I do like it now I
do want to see this red string the
second like I like this one a lot this
one's great that it's already there you
know maybe one goes across here and then
this last string I do want to see it
instead of going down like we see now I
want to see it go up like we're
following the camera's kind of following
it and that's like a you know it's kind
of a principle of motion like the the
string is leading our eye it's the
string is leading the camera across the
screen so you know there there's always
things I can tweak but that's one thing
I want to adust really quickly here if I
can find it so we're going to hit U on
the
keyboard and we're going to go back to
the starting point
here and we are going to
reverse and make sure I can find it
here
so let's say it's I want to get back
here to where it's not on screen so
right
there was it
100 no I think it needs to be at zero
but as we get
here there we
go should we go all the way to the end
here
here just like that and now you can see
the string is kind of leading the camera
on the end here which is nice I also
want to adjust this background comp here
I just want to bring it
over a little bit maybe something like
that and then the ambient light I also
want to bring it up this foreground
photo here at the end is just a little
too bright or a little too dark for me
so let's try 20
that's just too much overall so we'll
back that off and we'll take the first
Spotlight and we'll try and open up the
point of interest and kind of bring it
over that's another thing too is like
the the spotlight that could be
interesting if the spotlight starts
where it's at so point of Interest take
the key frame to the beginning here and
then it you know it's like the spotlight
is moving across like almost like
following that Spotlight that could be
really interesting
something like
this and here at the beginning let's
just actually bring the spotlight even
further over like this that's really
nice I like that a
lot makes it very moody and I'm going to
preview this and call it a day and that
my friends is how you use 3D lights and
shadows in After Effects with a camera
to create some really interesting depth
some three-dimensional depth now before
we go today I do want to remind you if
you have not downloaded my free pdf
guide the complete guide to organic
motion design please do motion science.
tvguide it's absolutely free and it's a
game Cher if you want to make less
digital looking renders as always thanks
for being here today I'll see you in the
next
video
[Music]